can I guess a I believe it was Michael
brought up his chest because your chest
in black panther we've got his shoes in
black panther this this caused a
sensation
there was an orthodontist that came
forward and said about this young woman
who came in yeah orthodontist had a
patient this this this this girl who was
watching black panther and I guess
during that scene she had her retainers
in and she clenched her jaws so tight
that she broke her retainers and that
kind of went viral and a buddy of mine
had sent it to me like hey man have you
seen this and I was like no that's wild
how do you even do that
and so I so I I sent her a damn I was
like hey I'm I'm sorry and I would love
to can I pay for your retainer or
whatever I saw her to pay for it and she
was like no no no that's why I have
insurance and I she was a very proper
answer I was like okay cool
she said you know if you're ever in the
Bay Area just you know let me know and I
would love to take a picture too and I
said okay cool and that was a trade-off
but it was it was it was it was yeah
she's not alone I mean you don't have to
go far on the Dean to have to find quite
extreme reactions to that scene but you
know shirt on
here's what somebody told Michael B
Jordan that my ovaries already my
procedure
[Music]
[Applause]
there's more there's more is another one
this Michael B Jordan make anyone else
want to rip their lungs out even erotic
reaction so creatives are so sexy I'm
gonna eat my lung I would selfie toes
and one kidney to be in the same room is
there a market for toes every time I
think about Michael B Jordan my uterus
combusts into clay that's wow that's
walking into ruko universe just burst
into flame
[Laughter]
[Music]
you